hello everyone this game here it's
basically a story of a magician taming a
dragon it was played in 1988 in Chicago
and McHale has the white pieces against
Robert forbus I couldn't find any
additional information on Robert for
forbus so the hoodie guy is back we
haven't had him in a while if any of you
can you know get any information on who
this person might be to share in the
comments and I will add any info you can
provide in the description below so for
many of you who are you know big fans of
the pirate like myself you've probably
already seen this game but for those of
you who are maybe new to chess and new
to the magician of riga mikhail tal you
will find this game immensely enjoyable
so so let's see this game Tull has the
white pieces and he goes for efore we
have c5 by Robert forbus the Sicilian
defense Knight to f3 d6 d4
C captures Knight captures and Knight to
f6 Knight to c3 and we have g6 the
dragon variation of the Sicilian Bishop
to e3 Bishop to g7 now and f3 preparing
the Yugoslavia TAC Knight to c6 we have
Queen to d2 black castles and now Bishop
to c4 here we have Knight to d7
preparing to transfer tonight to the
Queen side and tala goes for the attack
immediately he plays h4 we have Knight
to b6 attacking the bishop on c4 Bishop
to b3 retreating and now Knight to a5
forbus has the right idea he wants to
exchange his knight for this beautiful
Bishop on v3 that is slicing all the way
to the King tal ignores this there is
really nothing you can do you can't save
the bishop he plays h5 trying to break
break open the BH file so the H file
will be available for the rook Knight
beat the c4 now not going for the
LightSquared bishop but he decided to go
for this nice fork attacking the Queen
and the dark square bishop as the dark
square bishop is even more powerful in
this variation since in most cases white
will want to play Bishop to h6 exchange
the dark square bishop and then
at the open h-file queen is coming to h6
this will be this will be excellent for
white so by playing Knight to c4 the
Queen has to move and the dark square
Bishop will be captured next move Queen
to e2 Knight captures on e3 Queen
captures on e3 and here you have a
couple of options you know you can go
for some slow play like e6000 Bishop d7
and there's even an interesting idea of
developing a queen with tempo against
the knight on d4 but unfortunately this
doesn't work for example Knight the d5
is coming you can you can give up this
piece actually Queen captures on d4
Knight captures on e7 and in between
move King h8 and now we're queen capture
Sundy for Bishop captures and H captures
on g6 now the threat is rook captures
some h7 checkmate so you have to capture
it and now comes Knight captures on g6
King their knife capture screen captures
and after you castle you have quite a
lot of compensation for your exchange if
he does have two pieces for your rook
but these pawns will be incredible
you have a threat from your roof to the
bishop also this rook is prepared to
capture on h7 the position is much
better for white so after Queen to e3 of
course not going to be six like we
mentioned Knight captures an b3 is
played
grabbing both of talas bishops a capture
some b3 Bishop to d7 and now a queenside
castle we have E 6 now and f4 tower
towel pushes forward Queen to b6 now
kind of pinning this night since the
Queen is undefended on e3 tal pushes
even further f5 we have G captures on f5
and he captures on f5 and this is a very
complicated position to deal with when
you're playing with the black pieces
here he captures each captors on f5
doesn't doesn't really work not night is
coming to d5 and again you will have you
will have a lot of threats here for
white but after each character's on f5
there is the option of going a 5 and d5
is a very interesting variation for
black for example h6 Bishop to f6 but
now Knight to e4 again threatening to
capture the bishop with check v5 now now
the queen is protecting the bishop on f6
Knight captures Queen captures and
Knight to f3 attacking the e5 pawn so
it's a it's a pretty complicated
position white is somewhat better but
perhaps black could hold this but after
each captors an f5 black decided not to
capture not to the [ __ ] 5 he played
King to h8 and not allowing any future
Knight to d5 Knight to e7 with check
also now the rook can come to g8 to help
with the defense Tao played rook H 2 F 1
now the add protection to the f5 pawn
now if pawn captures Knight can capture
easily Bishop to d4 now and this is a
this is the idea what he was expecting
his queen capture some before and after
Queen captures rook captures and d5 and
it's a pretty good position for black
for both white and black I mean like
like Bishop on d7 isn't really doing
anything all of the points are on light
squares but perhaps something like b6
Bishop c8 followed by Bishop a6 can be
played in the future this Bishop will
gain some activity later but after
Bishop captures on d4 tall had a
different idea
tell played Queen rook captures on d4
here we have e 5 and it seems now the
rook has to move either to d3 or to e4
to protect the Queen and it seems like
mr. Robert forbus is able to exchange
Queens against style but such is not the
case tau plays Queen to h6 and what do
you play here well it's not really clear
how does white continue the attack after
black captures rook and it wasn't really
clear for Robert forbus
so he captured it Queen captures rook on
d4 and here at AA played Queen to f6
with check only move is King to g8 and
now comes Knight to d5 and this is a
beautiful move the threat of course is
Knight to e7 and this will be checkmate
and there is there is a big problem here
if you play Queen captures Knight the
head the knight is actually the fly
King the Queen from being able to defend
now comes Queen g5 check King to h8 and
after h6 there is no defense against
Queen to g7 checkmate if you try row be
g8 simply Queen to f6 the king he has
nowhere to go only move is rogue g7 and
how Queen captures on g7 this is
checkmate
so after this Knight to d5 move black
actually has a move that can save him
Robert forbus wasn't able to find this
move but we'll get back to this position
he tried look F to e8 making room for
the king at f8 and also now the rook is
guarding a 7 top plate Queen to g5 check
King to h8 and now h6 now tau is
threatening Queen to g7 checkmate so
this has to be stopped
efore now the Queen is also protecting
g7 and here comes f6 by tau now the
queen is no longer protecting g7 and
Queen to g7 checkmate is again a threat
Robert plate worked the g8 defending
checkmate
but here comes the Dragonslayer top
phase Queen to g7 and it's all over the
king has nowhere to go only movies rook
captures Queen which was played at rook
captures H captures King to g8 only move
and now comes Knight to e7 and this is
checkmate so this is this is I mean this
is beautiful this is what I like to see
you know they often asked Bobby Fischer
about what he thought about the purse
defense or defending with the dragon
Sicilian Bobby often said that it makes
no sense White was him to play f3 g 4h
for and black resigns the game well this
isn't the case when when someone very
strong uses those defenses but you know
it seems them when you're playing
against all it it often is the case but
like I said there was a moment after
this Knight to d5 this brilliancy by tau
where black had one moment where he
could play a better move and maybe
defend this position so you know do
check out the position I will give you a
couple of seconds if you want to pause
the video to find a move that saves
black so those are the seconds and for
those we who found it congratulations it
sits
not a very straightforward move the idea
how black says this is actually h6 and
this is actually creating a square for
Kingdom h7 so if you try Knight to d7
this is actually losing for white if
Knight to e7 check King h6
the King h7 now you have to play
something you don't really have a way to
continue this attack after Knight to g6
okay you can't capture the night but
black and simply play Bishop to c6 and
after Knight captures rook captures
there is no way for white to continue
this attack and there is no compensation
for a piece everything is guarded in the
white pawns are actually blocking white
from making any improvements and the
Queen can't really do anything here so
the idea after h6 is you can't play
Knight to e7 check so white would have
to capture the h6 bone but now the Queen
can capture the knight on d5 because
there is no h6 threat so after something
like rook to f3 threatening rook g3
there is f6 and now you're you're
creating an escape route for king king
f7 King g7 for example King the 18 c7
and white can't really allow this Ruby
g3 doesn't work so white in this
position would have to take the
perpetual check with Queen g6 King h8
Queen h6 King g8 Queen g6 check so yeah
there but this is a case in pretty much
every tile game you have that one chance
where you can defend properly if you
miss that then everything everything
goes then then it's a Dallas happy
hunting ground so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here I
would like to thank Adam levar abdullah
al windy and remedy rivera for a
contribution to my channel think a lot
of really appreciated thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon